bombardements qui ralentissent les
trains de réfugiés certains ont tout de
même pu atteindre à lviv grande ville de
l'ouest c'est là justement que se trouve
notre envoyé spécial sylvain rousseau
de l'électroménager des ordinateurs des
télévisions des téléphones toutes sortes
d'objets ont été déposées aujourd'hui à
lviv devant le consulat de russie
l'objectif est d'alerter l'opinion
publique sur les pillages systématiques
auxquelles sont accusés de se livrer les
soldats russes dans les zones qu'ils
contrôlent alors ces objets n'ont pas
été choisies au hasard ils sont basés
sur les interceptions des services de
renseignement ukrainiens des coups de
téléphone passés par le soldat passer
par les soldats vers leurs foyers vers
leur domicile vers leur famille pour
savoir de quelle sorte d'objet ils
avaient besoin l'objectif de cette
initiative privée est bien sûr de faire
tache d'huile puisque dans le monde
entier les gens sont appelés à faire la
même chose devant chaque ambassade russe
avec pour ambition d'alerter l'opinion
publique sur ces pratiques de façon à ce
qu'elle puisse enfin cesser